yeah welcome to this video playing wide
against an international master here
from France one job well let's go we
should be five yeah we've got this some
so-called Russell demo variation on down
it's been in fashion for a while now
probably age six now think it's no no he
allows this okay let's let's exchange
technically he's got the bad bishop but
still he got he's got two bishops so I'd
like to get rid of one of them plus the
question is candy castle now if he
canceled then maybe h4 h5 is really an
issue mmm does something entirely
different interesting yeah okay blackout
can go for this night f-86 maneuver and
just say okay you have a misplaced
bishop here but the tourists it's really
the case to know you cannot castle
quickly now he can go for long castling
but always let's see what what happens
I am okay yeah maybe you can do that
like Bishop to be seven and long castles
this is why I try to threaten a bit with
before can i play before now even i
think i can actually
I cannot take twice because of root be
one maybe even because of 95 I'm not not
one hundred percent sure and let and now
I thought be five so that I can occupy
the d5 square he's a bit slow in
development di Medici cannot castle I
mean he really am intentionally for
faded to this option now default doesn't
doesn't this black 452 disconnection
yeah well as often mentioned
disconnecting is the poor man's way of
resigning black black is black is busted
in on budget is supposed to do he takes
rupee one so it's over and he has no
roof like like this you can you it's
over the king is on on the eighth you
cannot cannot cancel short you cannot
castle long as having the same simply a
disaster yeah he should simply exchange
on on age six or play f6 something like
this this I mean Bishop f6 is probably
not not fatal but combined with all what
you did afterwards that is fatal I think
maybe a maybe instantly here set off be
6 9 f8 I don't know something like this
and then 96 2g for this looks better but
it doesn't make any sense to avoid the
exchange why why does he play Bishop f6
it doesn't really don't really work
together yeah well thanks for watching